ladies and gentlemen please welcome
Google's vice president of product
management developer and compute
platforms Sam Ramji
[Music]
[Applause]
good morning I can't tell you how
thrilled we are that you're all here
today I hope you've had a great
conference and I hope we blow your socks
off today with awesome technical content
and lots of open source so next has been
an amazing event so far and it's been
great to meet many of you in breakout
sessions in the hallways and even on the
street the vision Diane Greene shared on
the first day of next showcased the
evolution of Google cloud and how we're
growing extremely quickly with
enterprises and startups yesterday our
holes list show dust many of the new
releases and updates we've been working
on with Google cloud this week alone
we've announced more than 30 new
features and products that are now
available for everyone to take advantage
to build what's next now today we want
to take time and talk about one of the
things that fundamentally defines how
Google approaches the cloud today we
want to talk about openness to guide us
through the combined journey of open
source and Google is a person I've long
admired five-time co-chair of ozk on the
world's greatest open-source conference
she now leads open source communities
for Google cloud please join me in
welcoming another badass woman Sarah
Novotny
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
openness is about sharing openness is
about agreeing on common goals and
openness is about working together to
make better software and a better world
world Google's commitment to openness
has helped us hire many engineers and
allowed them to develop contribute to
and support many of the technologies
that are running the broader Internet
today a 2004 white paper on MapReduce
became the basis for many technologies
underlying the big data ecosystem
Google's internal system Borg for
managing containers was reimagined as
kubernetes an open-source container
orchestration system these are some of
the latest examples of collaboration
where openness has involved our industry
we at Google are humbled to take
advantage that over a billion users take
advantage of the services we provide to
openly share their content and services
as well as their dreams and achievements
it's cliche to say but we're standing on
the shoulders of giants all of this is
possible because of those that started
this journey toward an open world long
before Google was an idea thought up by
two grad students in Stanford in the
late 90s this morning we'll hear from
six speakers sharing particular facets
and benefits of openness as a philosophy
Vint Cerf Jim Zebulon Eric Brewer Chris
Wright and Jeff Dean and resentment
manga this story will I hope underpin
Google's commitment to open cloud and
why it is so strong as the internet was
being created one of the most important
decisions was to create and use open
standards and technologies to help
ensure that the network was both
resilient and easy to interconnect as
new systems came online it's this
commitment to openness that opened a
whole new world of interconnection
and has enabled the internet to become a
nearly universal means for exchange of
code information services and ideas the
decisions to make the internet based on
open standards were fundamental to
making it universal
just as the goals of open source and an
open cloud are critical to creating the
next generation of technical advances
Vint Cerf co-designed one of the key
parts of the Internet
tcp/ip he worked with the group that
helped connect the first two nodes to
ARPANET ran the internetting research
group and development program at DARPA
from 1976 to 1982 and was later
responsible for helping bring the first
commercial email system to the Internet
he's also responsible for helping form
ICANN was the first president of the
Internet Society and currently serves as
a commissioner for the United Nations
broadband Commission for Digital
development Hugh's were also working on
the interplanetary internet with NASA's
Jet Propulsion Laboratory here to share
his experience and knowledge about how
openness was a key design principle for
today's modern Internet is Vint Cerf
Thank You Sara
well good morning everyone this is a
wonderful opportunity to talk about the
thread of openness which weaves itself
throughout the internet story so let's
start can I get the first there we are
here's an example of a publication from
1974 I have the feeling some of you may
not have been born then this contained
the description of the Internet design
it was published openly by Bob Kahn and
me in this publication our design
intended to be available anywhere to
everyone with no barriers so he took no
patents we didn't make any intellectual
property claims and we did that on
purpose because we wanted there to be
absolutely no excuse not to adopt tcp/ip
as an international standard
so openness was important to us from the
get-go the request for comment series
which I suspect many of you are familiar
with was started in 1969 by my colleague
Steve Crocker who now happens to be
chairman of ICANN again openness the
intent here was to make sure that
everyone involved in the project and
other people who were interested could
see in detail how this stuff works what
the debates were about various choices
again open access to everyone the
internet itself has opened
characteristics and most of you I'm sure
very familiar with that at the core of
the Internet is the Internet Protocol
and it has this interesting property
it's stupid right it doesn't know the
packets of the Internet don't know how
they're being carried no idea if it's
going over a satellite link or an
optical fiber and it doesn't care like a
postcard doesn't care how it's being
carried and on top of everything else
the internet packets don't know what
they're carrying right they have no idea
it's the bag of bits going from point A
to point being with some probability
greater than zero that's all we ask of
it what's important is because they
don't know what they're carrying any
information has to be interpreted at the
edges of the net this is part of the
end-to-end principle so the point here
is that when you want to add a new
application you don't have to change the
net the net doesn't know that's open
with a Big O and so all the other
protocols did you see going up towards
the top and spreading out like
our evidence that if you aren't happy
with the protocols that exist now go
build your own if you're not happy with
the underlying transport mechanisms find
another one so this is open in every
sense of the word and that's why so many
new applications have been developed
over the last thirty some-odd years of
operation why does this thing there we
go
so here's an example at Google we
developed a new protocol called quick
that combines the TCP protocol with the
TLS protocols and adds a few other
features as well and that just slips
right in where TCP and TLS would
normally go and that runs right now in
our browsers and in our servers and in
other people's software who choose to
use this particular idea you might be
surprised to know that we were playing
around with packet voice and packet
video in the 1970s this is because the
military knew it was going to have to
use networking in order to carry voice
video and data we weren't carrying very
much though I can tell you our backbone
speeds were 50 kilobits a second back
that was broadband now it's a dial-up
modem but we were experimenting with the
concepts and actually trying this stuff
out the world wide web of course came
along Tim berners-lee invents this in
the late late 80s early 90s and is free
to do it right he and just invents a set
of protocols HTTP and HTML you know
encoding and he puts that up on the net
he doesn't have to get permission the
guys I started Google didn't have to get
permission from somebody to go put up
the service they just put it up in there
you know I guess it was in their dorm
room and then in a garage classic
Silicon Valley story but the whole point
here is it's permissionless innovation
and that's what the Internet has been
about and is still about and that's
what's important to you because if
you're thinking about starting new
businesses you want to be free to invent
you don't want to have to get permission
to try out your ideas and of course now
you see all the mobile apps and cloud
servers that are happening again
evidence of the permission lessness
of the internet here's another example
it's amazing everybody who got
browser and was curious how did they do
that had the opportunity to go look at
the source code boy that's open everyone
had a chance to try out new ideas steal
ideas from everybody else the whole
point is that we grew the notion of
webmaster from zero by people trying
each other's code out and out of you
know modifying and trying other ideas
and those got shared and propagated
almost organically this is such a
perfect example of why Open is so
important to everyone there's another
thing and that has to do with the
institutions that are part of the
internet we didn't create all of these
at the same time we created them when
they were needed so the internet
architecture board which used to be
called the internet configuration
control board when I was still in the
Defense Department I needed to have the
people who were running the project yet
together and talk to each other about
what was going on I wanted this to be
only the people I picked so the name of
this thing internet internet
configuration control board was picked
to be as boring as sounding as possible
so no one wanted to be on it except the
people I put on it that became the
internet architecture board which spun
out the internet Engineering Task Force
where all the standards get made now the
Internet Society was created in order to
support the internet Engineering Task
Force when the National Science
Foundation said we don't want to spend
any more research dollars on what has
become a very active commercial kind of
environment so the Internet Society was
formed to support IETF and now of course
it does a lot of other things as well
ICANN got created similarly around 1998
when the government decided the US
government decided why are we pretending
to be in charge of Internet address
allocation and domain name management
and the tables for the internet for the
Internet protocols why isn't that in the
private sector and so I can was created
as a multi-stakeholder group completely
open anyone is allowed to participate
and and become part of the policy-making
apparatus regional internet registries
are were created partly for convenience
so just spread the workload there are
five of them around
the world and they hand out internet
addresses to ISPs who subsequently make
those available to users and more
recently the Internet Governance forums
spun out of the world that was called
wisss the World Summit on the
information society this was originally
a multilateral intergovernmental thing
very quickly they discovered there was
more to the internet than government
than governments it was people like you
and me and so that blew up into the
Internet Governance forum a
multi-stakeholder annual event which now
has regional events to go with it all of
this stuff is wide open anyone is
allowed to participate and you should
too thank you very much
[Applause]
[Applause]
thanks vent now that we've established a
long-standing history of openness as an
underpinning philosophy behind our
modern communications marvel the
Internet it's important to understand
that adoption is how we've come to this
place in history to help us understand
how open-source has learned to balance
the tensions between openness and
business needs I'd like to introduce
Jim's Emlyn the executive director of
the Linux Foundation please join me in
welcoming Jim thank you
Wow following one of the fathers of the
internet big pressure I'm old enough to
have been around in 1974 but young
enough to is still run a dial-up BBS so
I'm flattered to be here and I'm honored
to work at an organization that's home
to one of the most successful
open-source projects in the world and I
don't need to convince this crowd how
important open-source is but I want to
remind you of how powerful open-source
is you just look at these statistics at
how far collaborative development has
come tens of thousands of files millions
of lines of code thousands of developers
on just one open-source project and
these stats are compelling but this is
my favorite statistic about Linux ten
thousand lines of code added five
thousand lines of code removed about
1,800 modified every single day 365 days
a year
there is no organization on earth that
can independently keep up with the pace
of development that's represented by
modern open-source processes in fact
open-source has become the new norm for
software development I mean really
nobody builds anything these days
without using open source code you know
the Internet is really built on open
source whether it's Google Facebook amaz
you name it it's all built on Linux and
a variety of open source in fact it's
more than a norm for software and the
internet open has become a new economic
norm an incredibly important norm as we
create more and more complex systems
that norm says something very very
simple but has been written about in
hundreds and hundreds of books and the
simple concept is all of us are smarter
than any one of us and I would go so far
as to argue that organizations
developers anyone who does not harvest
this great shared value that doesn't
participate in this collective
innovation will fail and I have some
good news for you the good news is
there's a lot of open source out there
you look at this just on github alone
there are 50 million open source
repositories and with this wealth of
code and ideas and collaboration one of
the questions that I get all of the time
is which projects really matter I mean
they're all great but which projects can
I bet my company on if I'm building a
cloud what can I bet my safety on if I'm
using open-source for an automobile
system which almost every modern
production vehicle uses today and we
spend a lot of time at the Linux
Foundation looking at that question and
our idea is that the answer to that
question are that the open source
projects that matter the most are those
that have sustainable ecosystems where
rich community solves a big problem
creates value that value is consumed by
companies like Google Microsoft Amazon
Facebook who then create profit
governments may save money increase
transparency and then that value in part
is hard
stood back into the project which begets
better code lather rinse repeat and
that's what foundations like mine and
the Apache Software Foundation and the
Eclipse Foundation really do you know
Vint talked about creating institutions
when they needed them with the growth of
the Internet we're creating the same
kind of institutions to enable the
growth of open source and these
institutions allow competitors and
collaborators to trust each other by
creating the institutions that enable
that trust a governance structure to
make decisions a development process
that enables people to scale out
development and sustain that development
for a long time
infrastructure whether it's things like
github or the wide variety of version
control systems
somebody needs to land a patch somewhere
that's what these organizations provide
ecosystem development how do you get
more developers to the party and then IP
management what license is the code
under who owns the trademark how do you
govern the intellectual property sharing
how do you share what you want to share
and keep what you want to keep that's
what organizations like mine and other
institutions are doing and open-source
projects that lean on these tend to be
the most enduring that's why last year
Google approached us and said we would
like to give up kubernetes we're gonna
give you the electoral property assets
the trademark and so forth we're gonna
create a shared development model with
our competitors and since that happened
kubernetes has been a rocket ship it is
on a trajectory similar to Linux in
terms of becoming essentially the Linux
of the cloud in terms of the developer
momentum the number of pull request
request times developers it's an
insanely fast growing project which
leads me to the last point which is I
work with over a thousand organizations
largely companies all over the world and
companies don't come to me and ask about
code what's tensorflow I want to see the
code they ask me about how to
the biggest problem in sharing and this
is the one thing you should remember for
me today is being a leader in
open-source takes work the human aspect
takes work being will the pull code in
modify that code share that code back
takes a process and Google is one of the
masters of that process and I want to
tip my hat to Google you know you talk
you hear about the term giffy you know
when kubernetes was open sourced it was
Google for everybody else right everyone
could take advantage of this container
technology in this great code but one of
the other insights I'd like to give you
from observing Google at over a decade
working with people like Chris DiBona
cat almond and others in the open-source
program offices code flows in and out of
Google seamlessly it's intentional learn
it and if you learn this you'll be able
to harvest that share at R&D and succeed
thank you very much
[Applause]
[Music]
thank you Jim it's wonderful to hear
that Google is perceived as a positive
influence in the open world and I can't
be happier to hear kubernetes referred
to as the Linux of the cloud but moving
on and Sam Ramsey who we will hear from
again later frequently refers to open
source and collaborative work as a
positive sum game Google has seen this
as a force multiplier and has been
intentional and long-standing in our
support of open source projects Eric
Brewer the VP of infrastructure and a
professor UC Berkeley focuses on all
aspects of internet-based systems
including cloud computing scalability
containers and storage as a researcher
he's led project on scalable servers
network infrastructure IOT and the cap
theorem today I'm delighted to hear his
thoughts on why an open cloud and open
source investment is as important as an
open Internet was 40 years ago please
join me in welcoming Eric brewer
[Applause]
all right fantastic to be here imagine
that you are in a new market and it's
the next big thing
giant giant giant but you have some
really big competitors and they have a
multi-year head start on you how are you
going to compete well that's what
happened to Linux these are projects
that Google is contributed to for more
than ten years a decade's worth of
contribution in these projects alone and
in the case of Linux 20 years ago the
next new thing was the web and Internet
services and honestly Linux was not a
very good Internet services operating
system
Yahoo used VSD Inc to me used Solaris
and they had a multi-year head start on
Linux in this space but Linux one why
did Linux win Linux one because it was
open but really because it had a higher
rate of innovation and so what matters
is not where you start what matters is
your rate of innovation even in
containers where we had 10 years of
contributions to learning from Google
that started out as something simple to
do kind of resource management things
like CPU sets and then C groups
additions to the Linux kernel that
allowed you to kind of manage your
resources and of course eventually led
to doctor and kubernetes which is where
we are today now there's a whole other
piece here which is open source is the
kind of leadership of an ecosystem so
you've probably heard of Android and
chrome those are open source projects
created not for their source code but
for their ecosystems the ecosystem is
how you steer a large community in a
collaborative way and certainly in the
cloud space tensorflow which are here
about from Jeff Dean a little bit and
kubernetes are in this mold we are
aiming to create open ecosystems that
have high rates of innovation and if
you've done know anything about
kubernetes you know it has a super crazy
high rate of innovation
that's kind of the whole point other
things on this list like basil and G RPC
are represent a different view which is
open source projects we created because
we feel like there was a googol way of
doing something internally that wasn't
understood externally GRDC is based on
something called stubby and basil is
based on an internal build system called
blaze both of which we really like and
we would like more people to use right
and in particular we'd like more people
to contribute to and to understand and
evolve now that's another kind of open
source it's the leadership part we take
a little aside from it you know those
slides you make sometimes where you put
a whole bunch of little text on it that
nobody can read and you do that because
you want to show how many things there
are well look at all these screens this
is a thousand plus open source projects
to which Googlers contributed in 2016 so
I had to put these extra screens to fit
them all except that this is only 10% of
the 15,000 that Google has contributed
to 2016 2500 of those had extensive
contributions right I was safe
legitimate ongoing things that were
evolving and in total again just in 2016
287,000 commits from Googlers using
their Google comm email addresses
meeting vets work-related not counting
the many many thousands more that we
don't know of which are on their
personal and gmail accounts right this
is stuff where we believe it's worth the
investment to make these systems better
right fundamental definitely view on
what we want to get out of this there's
another kind of open source support
which is actually just plain old
financial so these are foundations that
we support directly events we run 50 or
help run fund 50 to 75 different kinds
of events throughout the year
all over the world this is also where
things like google Summer of Code fit
trying to expand the community of
open-source contributors there's another
kind of support as well which is
security we live in a difficult time
from the security viewpoint and we have
a shared fate right we are all using the
same core pieces and we will make it or
not together right so an important kind
of contribution is to improve the
security of the world systems and
open-source makes that significantly
easier so in the last years few years
Google's fixed more than a hundred
security bugs in Linux in Chrome and in
December we released a tool called open
fuzz and the purpose of open fuzz is
essentially to allow you to do fuzz
testing on your own code and improve
your security and in fact it will even
help you make the right patch so all
this is to say that open matters to
Google but I'd go farther to say to open
matters more for the cloud because in
the cloud we are on a joint mission to
build the world software right it is
fundamentally collaborative the
collaboration is on the code right and
so our strategy here is be the open
cloud have the faster rate of innovation
have more collaboration write read the
place where collaboration occurs and
it's not completely altruistic right
when I got to Google six years ago one
of its challenges which remains a little
bit but not as much is that its internal
systems although they drew from many
open source projects were very exotic so
they've their own little internal
systems of ways to build things when you
come in as an outside developer it was
very difficult to be productive in the
first six months because whatever you
knew coming in you had to learn
different systems to make progress as we
move to open systems things like to
kubernetes and tensorflow
Google benefits by being more like the
rest of the world that's a much more
sustainable place to be and so that's
another reason we're embracing openness
in a fundamental way let me close on one
last thought
which is in the end the reason that
matters to customers as I think is the
freedom and buy freedom in this case
what I mean is that the same code runs
on Prem and in Google Cloud the same
code runs on multiple clouds and you can
decide for your code when to run it on
Fram when to run it in the cloud if you
want to migrate the cloud you choose the
time line and you choose the steps and
if you don't like something you can
leave right freedom means freedom to
leave but it also means freedom to join
right so the strategy here is very
simple we're gonna be the open cloud
we're gonna innovate faster we're gonna
give you the freedom to leave and the
freedom to join and I'll take my chances
thank you
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
open matters more for the cloud that's a
pretty powerful message co-development
with our customers and our partners as a
philosophical underpinning of the Google
cloud strategy hybrid and multi cloud is
not a waypoint
on your journey but a goal that empowers
you and allows while allowing
encouraging you our customers to choose
the services which meet your needs we
want to support you and the tools you
know and have while allowing you to take
advantage of the tooling and
infrastructure that only Google can
provide this sort of collaboration with
customers and partners through
open-source is something that Red Hat
has a long history of doing well Chris
Wright vice president and chief
technologist at Red Hat has also worked
for many of his 20 years directly on
upstream open source technologies like
Linux Xen KVM open switch and OpenStack
today he's going to share with us how
collaboration open source and
enterprises can work together to benefit
the industry it's my pleasure to
introduce Chris Wright
[Music]
all right really great to be here that's
unusual for me to be on a stage after
hearing about the openness and
introduction of the Internet so I'm
excited to be here to share with you
some of my thoughts and my experiences
in open source collaboration and and
bringing that to the enterprise so first
I'll start with a personal story about
12 years ago Brian Stevens who's then at
Red Hat's contacted me about joining Red
Hat and I was 100% focused on upstream
development
I was definitely skeptical about what
the relationship between
commercialization and enterprise focus
might do to my focus in terms of
upstream and so I came up with a list of
reasons to all the reasons what I was
gonna say no and Brian neutralized each
one of those I had one final reason and
that was my wife and I were expecting
our first child and I thought maybe two
two big changes at once isn't a great
idea but one thing really persisted and
stuck with me and that was the idea that
I really like working with customers
understanding customer problems and
helping them solve their issues in the
context of open source that's exactly
what we do at Red Hat we spend our time
with our customers distilling their
requirements into upstream code
delivering that as products really
harnessing open source innovation to
deliver the value of open source to the
enterprise so let's take a look what it
what is the enterprise you look inside
the enterprise and it is a collection of
highly heterogeneous systems that have
evolved over long periods of time inside
the enterprise is a bit of everything
you look at compute you got mainframe
you've got RISC UNIX you got modern x86
and Linux on the networking side you've
got switches and routers and server NICs
from different vendors different
generations of technology storage fibre
channel
Ethernet direct-attached you've got
different authentication from LDAP to
Active Directory you've got process
change management ISO and I toe all of
this creates a complex system and
complex systems with complexity comes
fragility the mission critical nature of
opens of enterprise applications creates
a risk-averse environment and these
siloed areas of expertise slows
collaboration so the enterprise data
center is an artisan handcrafted special
snowflake the IT groups have been sort
of relegated to a cost center with a
mandate from CIOs to really reduce costs
or do more for less and here open source
comes in and something like Linux builds
a standard platform decoupling the
hardware layer from the application
layer the industry-wide collaboration
helps craft this core platform and adapt
it to all of the unique requirements
that you find in any one enterprise
again that's what we're doing with our
customers were we're understanding those
requirements we're taking those in the
upstream communities developing code and
delivering those as products and
supporting that with our customer but
the enterprise is changing business
world is much more competitive today
things are moving quickly and it's
software that differentiates businesses
the ability to adapt to market changes
requires efficiency you need to be able
to build high value software and deliver
it quickly in order to do that you need
to standardize and automate for both
developers and operations efficiency the
enterprise is really looking to the web
scale companies to understand how they
can improve this efficiency building
things out of microservice software
architectures using containers to
package up services and direct
dependencies
using CI CD pipeline to deliver this
into a hybrid cloud at cloud scale risk
is mitigated by small incremental change
and those silos are broken down by
cross-functional teams so we built open
shift to address those those needs for
for our customers and OpenShift
you know building this kind of modern
web scale application platform we built
it out of low-level Linux container
building blocks
so inside OpenShift we had a unique to
open shipped implementation of
containers and container orchestration
you could call it our our own snowflake
open-source communities are really
driving technology innovation so you see
containers go mainstream through tools
like docker the experience from borg
captured and brought to mainstream by
kubernetes and what we saw was an
opportunity to take that innovation
rebase ourselves as OpenShift
onto these mainstream projects and
deliver that value to our customers
while being able to take on the rapid
innovation and these these communities
that are much larger than ourselves so
letting go a little bit really gave us a
huge you know a huge lift today we're
not just contributing to to open shift
or docker kubernetes but we're
contributing to the community at large
and we're contributing to our partners
and competitors
we're helping gke we're helping other
kubernetes based distributions our
developers are thrilled by the success
story and the contribution that they've
had to something like pokemons go what a
cool story and to know that you've been
a part of that is a great sense of
settings a great sense of satisfaction
so open source collaboration benefits
everyone
diversity is a really important
component of the communities that we're
building here and if you look to ecology
a lot of studies showing biodiversity
creates a strong ecosystem here we're
talking about diversity of users
diversity of developers diversity of
customers and vendors diversity of use
cases and requirements driven by these
customers and vendors addressing
different markets the end result in an
open-source collaborative community is
continual refinement code refactoring
architectural improvements to take on
all those requirements building a
platform that is more maintainable and
sustainable into the future will
continue over time to grow and change
and adapt and that is exactly what we're
doing together today in communities like
kubernetes and we look forward to
continue doing that together thank you
[Applause]
collaboration and diversity of thought
only make our projects stronger
open-source development in active
communities enable perspectives that
anyone company developing a product
cannot see working together makes
open-source platform and infrastructure
software and projects stronger and more
useful to a broader array of users in
addition to all the projects which
Google is contributed to over its
lifetime there are hundreds of projects
that Google has founded and maintains in
a transparent manner Chris mentioned one
of our highlights kubernetes began as a
company led project and is growing
toward community leadership a few
statistics on the community kubernetes
project again my favorite show the crazy
level of engagement we have well we have
more than a thousand code contributors
over the lifetime of the project there
are many more ways to participate in
open source in February more than 700
people in people commented on and
created issues offered pull requests and
reviews and generally participated in
the kubernetes project on github alone
beyond the sheer number of people who
are participating their engagement is
unprecedented those 700 community
members interacted with the kubernetes
project on github an average of 15 times
if my math is correct that's more than
10,000 events changing kubernetes in
February in github alone beyond that we
have special interest groups we have
mailing lists a conversation about
Google's open source commitments
wouldn't be complete without a view into
another highly visible open source
project tensorflow and kubernetes
compete for the top position for most
engaged project most months and here to
correct me if tensorflow is leading in
March is our senior fellow from Google
Jeff Dean
[Music]
[Music]
all right Thank You Sara so I'm going to
talk to you today about tensorflow
which is a machine learning platform our
group has been building to help support
our research and to get the machine
learning systems deployed throughout
Google so I lead the Google brain team
which is our artificial intelligence
research team in Mountain View and our
group does long-term research so we need
a platform that's very flexible to allow
us to express lots of different kinds of
machine learning ideas and also to
interact with the machine learning
community we published papers so our
group built an earlier system called
disbelief that we did on open source and
then use that for a couple of years for
our research and for some product juices
and then as we were thinking about what
we wanted to do next
we took the ideas that were good about
disbelief but also fixed a bunch of the
things that we didn't like about it and
created tensorflow and from the
beginning I argued that we should
open-source tensorflow and really make
it a common platform for everyone in the
world not just people within Google and
so by open sourcing this we actually
allow lots of people to benefit from
machine learning and being able to use
machine learning in their products to do
more advanced machine learning research
and to really create a community around
it so why open source it one of the
things we like to do is publish research
papers about our work and by open
sourcing sort of reference
implementations of some of the code used
to create the experiments in the papers
we allow people to more easily replicate
our research we also allow people to
take those ideas and use them in their
sort of product applications of machine
learning so things like computer vision
models they can use in a lot of
different ways in various products of
either running on devices or running in
cloud and we really want to bring
machine learning to everyone there's
billions of people in the world millions
of developers who can benefit from using
machine learning to accomplish things
that are hard to accomplish other ways
so here's a graph of kind of out the
internal spread of machine learning and
tensorflow usage within Google and one
of the things we do is
a team is build this system so that
everyone can benefit within Google and
we spread ideas and as teams pick up
machine learning other teams see that
and see that it would be applicable to
their kinds of problems and so you see
it being used for many many different
things there's about four thousand
directories now that contain tensorflow
configuration files within Google so
it's being used by hundreds or even
thousands of teams it's used in popular
products like Gmail and YouTube and
translate search and it's also because
we open sourced it it's now the number
one machine learning repository and
github and people have really taken to
it as a way to express machine learning
research ideas to use machine learning
code in their products in various ways
and just to show you what a ride it's
been since we open-source that we open
sourced it in November 2015 and this is
a comparison with a bunch of other sort
of open-source machine learning projects
that most of which have been around for
for quite a bit longer and we have a
pretty engaged community and that that's
really valuable to us we're getting lots
of good feedback getting lots of
information about you know what kinds of
things we should be working on as a
community and I think one of the reasons
it's gone well so far is that we've
continued to innovate and create new and
improved versions of tensorflow and add
features that people really request so
some just a highlight a few you know
every couple of months we've been doing
minor version release we just had our
1.0 release and we released distributed
tensorflow
which is a big requested feature added
support for lots of platforms like iOS
and Mac and Windows worked a lot of
performance for our 1.0 release which
was last month so that's been great and
the other thing is I think is a really
important is that it runs on lots of
different platforms we want machine
learning to run wherever it needs to be
run that includes CPUs GPUs GPUs our
custom machine learning accelerator
chips Android iOS Raspberry Pi all these
things are important so here to tell you
more about the community that we've
built up is rashad manga who heads up
our tensorflow development efforts
within our our team thank you
[Applause]
thank you Jeff so Jeff talked about a
number of things about tensorflow
one of the most important things we feel
about any open-source project as the
community and you heard a lot of
speakers earlier talk about this so
let's look at the great open source
community that we have with nearly 500
contributors from outside Google and
many more within Google as well and
nearly 15,000 commits or updates to the
source code over the last year the last
14 15 months it's a very active project
there's lots going on lots of
development it's one of the most active
projects out there we engage directly
with the community we look at the sack
overflow we work on you know we have
over 5,000 questions that have been
answered by us and the community itself
and over a hundred new community
submitted issues that are responded to
are fixed every single week it's being
used very widely in academia so you know
some of the top universities are using
it from their machine learning courses
in fact Stanford just offered a course
specifically to train their students or
intensive flows how they could use it
for all kinds of machine learning work
Jeff showed some of this there are many
different products at Google that use
tensorflow now this is just some of them
so YouTube uses it for recommendations
Gmail uses it for spam it's part of the
cloud platform for the machine learning
itself and many other uses right but
open source was not just for Google
really with that we've made it available
to many companies out there and again
this is a small list of companies that
are using it today many of these are
building products for users like
yourself or many others out there
it doesn't stop at these large companies
though machine learning is really for
everyone and there are many people out
there who are just hobbyists or trying
it out or trying to solve real problems
and this makes it possible for them to
do it let's take a look at a few
examples of what people have been doing
with tons of low
so you might have seen this demo out
there for cucumbers sorting so there's
this cucumber farmer in Japan who has a
large cucumber farm and one of the
things that needs to be done is once you
have the cucumbers to sort them by size
or shape this used to be a manual work
roughly 8 hours a day mostly done by the
mother shown out there and so the son
decided okay let's see if we can
automate some of this so he took a whole
bunch of pictures of these cucumbers
download you gents intensive low
training trainer model to identify and
sort them and then ran it on a Raspberry
Pi connected it to an Arduino and just
automated that whole process all by
himself
pretty amazing use of trance flow thank
you machine learning has become becoming
very important for health care and here
I just wanted to show a couple of
examples how it's been used in health
care so the one on the left is a nature
article for something that was done at
Stanford by students there who again you
know collected a whole bunch of pictures
about skin lesions and which separated
them from okay these are cancerous these
are not trained a neural network or to
learn from that and identify which ones
are cancerous and they actually have a
model that performs nearly as well as
dermatologists so it can be you know
great for users another example is in
our team we looked at pictures of the
eye the frontal images that you see on
the right and again trying to identify
if a user has diabetic retinopathy or
not and you know again once you collect
a data set trainer model it ends up
doing really really well so if you see
how many doctors there are in the world
and how many patients they are there's
no way we can you know we don't have
enough doctors to reach every patient
this is a great way that machine
learning can really help people who have
no chance of getting access to doctors
today
[Applause]
thank you
[Applause]
thanks Jeff and Rashad I have to say
your community has done some amazing
things I would never have expected with
the tensorflow platform cucumbers that
creativity is one of my favorite
second-order effects of open development
and open communities open development is
both a benefit and a responsibility with
a tight feedback loop
I mentioned that open development and a
commitment to open source is also a draw
to good developers I count our new VP
Sam Ramsay among those who were drawn to
Google because of a commitment to
openness please join me in welcoming the
former CEO of Apogee and Cloud Foundry
foundation here to share his vision on
open development Sam Ramsey
[Music]
[Applause]
all right how are we doing so far
pretty awesome not totally sure what I'm
doing on the same stage as the inventor
of the internet inventor of kubernetes
inventor of tensorflow
but I thought it'd take a minute and
offer sort of my frame like how do I
think about this stuff how does Google
think about openness we think this is
the best time in history to be a
developer our craft is respected our
work has been elevated and we're in an
era of rising demand this is our time
now as companies have realized they have
to become digital businesses they have
figured out that this transformation is
powered by developers so as much as this
is our time the stakes are high we have
responsibilities to our craft to each
other and to the world the developers
never had before high among them is the
need to create systems that are secure
flexible and open late last year I came
to Google cloud because I felt there was
no better way no better place to make
real all of the good that open-source
promises and take it further in a way
that can impact all the places software
is going with what we call the open
cloud our tools your tools
your systems have to make sense they
have to be connected to be efficient
they have to be open so we can shape
them how we need them to be we can
create the age of open development now
open development demands openness in
every dimension open api's open source
and open clouds when we have access to
every part of our technology environment
we can build the system we require to
develop at the speed we need openness
lets us make unexpected combinations so
for example both cloud foundry and
kubernetes are inspired by Google's Borg
and we started to see these communities
come together around a project called
the open service broker API that lets
cloud foundry and kubernetes deployed
applications call each other
discover and consume each other services
now recently users who have deep
investments in cloud foundry asked for a
way to run kubernetes on top of Bosch
that's tooling that they're already
comfortable with that sits under CF now
engineers from pivotal and Google took
this to heart
worked with the customers requesting the
capability and made the necessary
updates to Bosch this new tool set is
packaged as Kubo kubernetes on Bosch
and today Kubo is open its pre-alpha
open source on github available today I
expect more cloud foundry installations
we'll look to add kubernetes to their
environments now to quote Sarah Novotny
this is composable infrastructure at its
finest applications written with open
principles help us however much is
possible reason about and future proof
our applications think about this
everyday critical information on logic
is accessed from and pour it into a wide
variety of legacy systems built years
ago using proprietary protocols they
weren't all following Vint Cerf's advice
to start open and stay open so whatever
we build today is actually tomorrow's
legacy one of my favorite job titles
I've ever read was in a book called a
fire upon the deep anybody read a fire
upon the deep Vince a Vernor Vinge
brilliant book recommended to me by
jeremy allison who's the maintainer of
samba it set tens of thousands of years
from now and the story is built on
intertel travel but without breaking
Lightspeed so they use cold sleep and
the ships have to last thousands of
years now of course these ships are
massively automated through software and
new software is constantly being written
to solve new problems for the really old
problems the boring problems like core
life-support systems they have really
old software what's the job title
programmer archaeologist so let's have
some empathy for the developers who will
come after us right and build our
applications to be open to the future
there's also an element here of software
as oral history to quote James governor
and we need to keep sharing ideas about
the code we write as much as we share
the code we write so we have valuable
but old applications stuck on old
hardware and we have new and future
legacy applications that we run on
elastic platforms like kubernetes and
Google Cloud and we have data that
drives those applications and results
from those applications both input and
output generally that data is wherever
the applications are and shares the same
constraints we also have new modes of
computing that are far from the desktop
even mobile clients and the apps on
those are starting to look like old hat
we're getting data from lightbulbs we're
running apps on oil rigs and in surgery
centers and we're trying to make sense
of all of it with analytics for the
really hard analysis problems we're
using machine learning
now I graduated in 1994 with a degree
focused on AI and nurse
science if you said AI back then you
went to the back of the hiring queue it
was the AI winter so for a while we
concealed it under the safe we're
heading a machine learning but it's
faithfully set on Wednesday the AI
winter is open and it is time for the
doc democratization of AI
long live AI so finally we've got the
product managers the marketing managers
and the analysts who are all trying to
figure out if this thing is working
right is this just technology or is this
really business you know the proof as
they say is in the spreadsheet so we
even need to make these systems open to
spreadsheets so we can bring those users
on board because business users matter
to open development is the pattern we
see everyone heading towards it's made
out of open api's open source and open
clouds API SWAT everywhere we use them
to get to modern services like Twilio
and bigquery we roll our own over our
own custom micro services and we wrap
them around legacy systems like general
Ledger's and mainframes they have to be
open to be really useful they have to be
openly documented using standards like
the open API spec they have to use open
protocols like HTTP and G RPC they have
to use open formats often JSON but
sometimes XML open api's have to be
available to be called from anywhere not
just by code running in the API
providers cloud think about that you
should be able to call that anywhere in
case you have to move your warp load
later and if you're looking for the
business angle researchers like Marshall
Van Alstyne at the MIT initiative on the
digital economy have even demonstrated
the businesses with open api's grow
faster and are more profitable so open
source is a modern developers basic
expectation and the default licensing
model for nearly all development tools
open source is a positive sum game where
no one needs to lose in order for
someone else to win as Eric Jeff and
Rajotte showed at Google we believe in
offering technical ideas as open source
like angular Android v8 go G RPC Apache
Beam kubernetes and tensorflow and
really important we believe in giving
back to open source projects where we
have something to contribute and where
we received so much value like Linux KVM
MySQL Python
she eclipses nodejs samba and many
others and additionally we give
opportunities to high school and college
students every year to build open source
projects while being mentored by open
source developers and luminaries in two
programs Google Summer of Code and
Google Code in this is to quote Jim's
Ellen the new normal open source
altogether this is what we need for open
development now when I met Bryan Stevens
last year the thing he said that made me
stop and fundamentally reassess Google's
cloud was this simple statement we are
building an open cloud that's our
strategy I was kind of stunned I had to
dig deeper and you can see where my
exploration led me in hindsight I really
shouldn't have been surprised because
Bryan spent 14 years of deck building
open systems and another 14 years at Red
Hat making Linux the enterprise standard
open clouds are the new idea in this
stack so if we're doing open development
on open api's and open source
shouldn't we want an open cloud about
six years ago at AWS Khan in 2011 I and
several other people started a nonprofit
called the open cloud initiative we
could see the coming era of cloud
computing bringing a Pandora's box of
exclusion and lock-in and that the open
source definition didn't guide the cloud
the nonprofit wound down but the ideas
live on users win in an open cloud so an
open cloud is open source friendly it's
both accepting open source and giving
back to it we aim to be the best place
to run open source stacks we're
contributing to open source cloud
computing projects including core
technologies like kubernetes and
tensorflow and working with docker cloud
foundry and OpenStack we think Chris
Wright and the Red Hat team for helping
us see the value and collaboratively
developing kubernetes an open cloud
supports open access with no barriers to
entry or exit you should be able to
bring your own artifacts VMs containers
language runtime and framework you'd be
able to take your things out as docker
containers yamo files in standard
databases you should be able to sign in
with OAuth you should be able to connect
with enterprise and social identities
you should be able to see the logs of
everything that's happened access
transparency is crucial and finally an
open cloud is home to an open ecosystem
plugging the platform developer
community directly into the providers
all kinds of services now let me pause
here this is important so service is
built by communities and companies
should get all the same representation
and distribution as services built by
the cloud provider open innovation means
open to a world of ideas and not
assuming that our implementation of
Cassandra or Postgres is the best
possible one so there's a big idea in
here that could help democratize
enterprise software the way that
smartphones democratize consumer
software more services each excellent
smaller and scope built profitably by
smaller teams so I think if we work on
this together we can get the software
industry to something sleek adaptable
and sustainable finally developers are
tying all of these things together into
the systems they need to work at speed
systems of continuous integration and
continuous deployment
it's the on-ramp to everything good in
modern software development developers
taking responsible for testing and
production it goes without saying that
they're using open-source tool is like
chef ansible puppet salt cloud foundry
gitlab Jenkins concourse and spinnaker
this is a concourse screenshot and today
these systems are unique to each
Enterprise there is unique as your
nervous system and often unique to each
development team in the future we may
see common patterns emerge that we can
simplify and standardize so at Google we
want everyone to benefit from an open
cloud so to help make that possible
today we're announcing an expansion of
our Google platform Google cloud
platform free offerings so first your
credits will last for a year
second we will have a level of compute
storage messaging and server lists that
will always be free but most importantly
we are walking our talk about the open
ecosystem you can spend your credits on
our ecosystem partners through the
Google cloud launcher
we will pay developers who built these
services for your trial experience
because your platform is our whole
ecosystem this is what open development
looks like to us
so open API is open source and open
cloud we believe in open collaboration
working engineer to engineer we're
moving from just writing papers about
Borg and BigTable to actually sharing
the code we're writing books on systems
reliability engineering and we want to
move the state of the art forward in
both development and operations which
together make up the discipline of
engineering we're deploying our
engineers to work directly with you on
your critical projects so we expect you
to hold us accountable to this vision I
may make a point negative feedback as a
gift it's a declaration of what's
missing like negative space it says this
is missing but if platform had this it
would be awesome so let me close by
saying we're glad you're here I'm glad
you're here let's build great things
thank you
so it's my great pleasure to welcome my
friend and colleague Allyson wagon Feld
she's the chief marketing officer of
Google cloud and one of the awesome
parts of my job is I get to work with
Allyson every day
please welcome
[Applause]
[Music]
good morning welcome thank you for being
here I'm humbled and privileged to be
able to bring to market the incredible
technology that my colleagues and others
have been building over decades building
it with the open cloud community we're
now going to transition to the second
part of our program this morning where
we have the opportunity to hear from
three great startups that are doing
really interesting work engaging with
the community and building on Google
Cloud and with Google cloud first we'll
have the opportunity to hear from will
Marshall founder and CEO of Planet two
incredible work using satellite imagery
second we'll hear from Willem founder
and CEO of Oden technologies is really
transforming manufacturing with the
democratization of AI and third Herman
the CEO of improbable will share great
work they're doing it's a london-based
company with simulations and gaming and
virtual worlds so now please join me in
welcoming will to the stage
[Music]
[Applause]
good morning my name is will Marshall I
am the CEO and co-founder of planet and
planets mission is to image every point
on the Earth's surface and make change
visible accessible and actionable we do
this with a network of over a hundred
satellites that we've designed built and
operate in space today in fact today
Planet operates the largest fleet of
satellites in human history unlike
traditional satellites ours a much
smaller and in fact we built 13
different iterations of these satellites
and launched them on 13 different
Rockets over the last few years to
constantly improve our capability in
space we call this agile aerospace and a
few weeks ago we launched our latest
fleet of 88 satellites on this rocket
it's the largest number of satellites
ever deployed from a rocket in human
history
it was pretty nerve-wracking but
freaking cool
[Music]
but as cooler space stuff is and like a
geek out all day that's not why I'm here
to talk about you see the bats at lights
for us our back end what they enable is
what's really important and that's the
data that they can reduce and
particularly the imagery see traditional
satellite imagery you find online is old
and with the 149 satellites that we
operate today in space we have the
capacity to image every point on the
land area of the earth every single day
and see change as it happens we see
every port every city every farm every
forest across the whole earth every day
and the highest level this data is
useful for many things but the highest
level is useful for us to help take care
of our changing planet here a couple of
images so you get a sense for what we
can see here's an oil refinery you can
see ships you can see roads you can see
buildings you can see individual trees
here you can see another port area you
can just about see vehicles and roads
but you can't see people or read number
plates this is about wide scale change
but our capability is being enhanced
because we recently announced that we're
going to be acquiring Terra Bella google
satellite arm and which with which we
will be gaining seven and soon 13 high
resolution satellites in orbit to
complement this and in fact the
satellites the medium wares and the high
resolution satellite data is very
complementary so what does this all mean
well for one thing it means a shed ton
of data and dramatically increasing
amounts every single day terabytes
coming down documenting changes around
our planet and we need to get this data
quickly and reliably to our users and so
yesterday we were pleased to announce
that we have switched to Google cloud to
host our imagery and do our data
processing
and whilst there's a handful of
companies that can offer storage and
processing we were really impressed by
Google clouds core technology especially
the machine learning trajectory in both
hardware and software that we figure be
very useful as was the deep
understanding of geospatial data and I'd
like to thank the senior leadership team
at Google cloud as well as in particular
Diane Greene for for working with them
but this least so important announcement
today you see a planet we believe our
imagery should be available to everyone
not just the big gun companies and
governments that have accessed satellite
imagery to date and so if we can advance
the slide one more that's why I'm
excited today to announce the release of
planet Explorer beta we want to get data
into the hands of individuals smaller
medium-sized businesses NGOs developers
researchers around the planet planet
Explorer beta is the first global
platform updated every month with
imagery of the entire planet no login
required planet Explorer enables the us
to see the time element to satellite
imagery let me show you how it works
anyone who goes to Planet comm can view
our images on a monthly and quarterly
basis each global base map is made up of
millions literally millions of
individual satellite imagery so as we've
stitched together using the timeline you
can navigate quickly across the world in
space and in time to date satellite maps
have been static and we've changed that
that planet has added the time axis to
Maps that's the key difference let's
take a look at Gilroy in California to
zoom in and see a little bit closer what
you can see so if we zoom in here when
you zoom in you can see changes on a
much more granular level you can see in
this case the fields changing
with the various harvesting processes in
these fields but there's more once you
log in and you can do so with a free
account you can see a full set set of
imagery we have taken imagery one second
we've taken on average more than a
hundred fifty images of every point on
the land area of the Earth's surface and
you can browse this full stack of
imagery with a free account you can see
those new images as they come down by
the day by day and you can compare
changes as they happen with a change
tool that allows you to see changes as
they happen day by day like in good ways
seeing the changes in the flooding
planet Explorer enables us to easily
visualize change and compare and see the
changes it happens around the planet
there are limits planet at present time
is limited in zoom outside the US and
the imagery is available on their
browser for personal non-commercial use
we encourage commercial use of course
but for that you have to sign up for a
paid account and then you can download
our full imagery and and full resolution
now there are zillions of use cases of
this data which is why we've created an
open API to build applications on top of
it here's a few examples imagine on a
commercial side you can count ships into
and out of ports in this case ships into
and out of the port of Sydney you can
track deforestation and even measure
carbon stocks here in this case in
Bolivia earlier this week our partners
decart lab we released the geo visual
search here user highlights a feature
and then it goes ahead and finds those
features across our whole imagery in
this case solar arrays in the whole of
in a whole of China it's pretty freakin
cool
our partners and developers are building
apps on our geospatial data and we want
to grow this community which is why I'm
here today to invite you to come and
join our global community of developers
with planet Explorer beta running on
Google Cloud
Panama is now delivering powerful
insights about our changing planet made
available online at your fingertips the
goal of this is to enable users to
browse our imagery and explore how it
can help their needs we hope they will
lead to more commercial partnerships
more benefits on the humanitarian side
you've been used to static maps and
planet Explorer you now get the real
view which is a constantly changing
planet planet has added the time access
to maps and anyone can come to Planet
comm today to view that imagery we
invite you to come and explore with us
thank you very much
[Applause]
and now I'm introducing Willam from
olden technologies who's going to join
us on stage
[Music]
hi my name is William Sandler I'm
co-founder and CEO of Oden Technologies
I'm here to talk about the most
important sector in the US economy
manufacturing in 2015 gross output of US
factories was 6.2 trillion dollars or 36
percent of GDP it's easy to forget that
the car you drive beat of Volvo Ford
Tesla it's not just built by Volvo Ford
and Tesla it's made up of with some
30,000 components coming from a complex
network of manufacturing suppliers these
manufacturers they make everything that
we take for granted in our daily lives
but they have not seen the benefits of
the technological advancements that have
happened in the computer industry and
our consumer lives in the past 15 20
years take the US plastics industry as
an example sixteen thousand factories
output of about three hundred and
seventy billion dollars but most of the
data they collect and analyze to
continuously improve their production is
done with clipboards and timers pen and
paper I'm not saying that there isn't
industrial technology but it hasn't been
accessible to the wider audience
it's only been accessible to the 1% of
manufacturers most of the hardware is
built on programmable logic controllers
almost all software is hosted locally
design of it looks like it's from the
90s at best 80s if you're less lucky and
it's always been extremely expensive and
can take months to years to implement
even but it doesn't have to be that way
anymore
through ubiquity of networks drastic
decrease in cost of electronics and
cloud computing coupled with a
tremendous growth and power and tools
that are available superior technology
is now accessible by manufacturers large
and small and all verticals we found it
Odin with a core mission to empower
manufacturers with data and tools so
they can eliminate waste in their
production decrease trap rates decrease
machine failures and unplanned downtime
understand their settings and minimize
the material consumption so that every
manufacturer can make the most of their
capacity and make awesome products for
us to do this
we built a device based on the Raspberry
Pi that can communicate with most
industrial machinery and external
sensors take data in real time central
cloud-based analytics platform the data
that we're collecting can be granular
information about how the material is
behaving throughout the process what's
happening inside of the machine belts a
higher level metrics like what's the
throughput per hour per rpm per
horsepower was the utilization of your
production lines or your whole factories
and we do this built and hosted
completely on Google cloud platform the
millions and millions and data points
that we collect our production line per
day
suggested with pub/sub a real-time
stream processing framework we can do
complex transformations on the data
lives in container engine we're about to
move that to dataflow storage BigTable
and the micro services that support our
platform olives in container engine on
the web application itself compute
engine so manufacturers get real-time
stream with all the important metrics
coming from their production lines so
they can take better decisions in
real-time high-level overview of whole
production of lines or multiple
factories on your utilization state
throughput what products are making
complete traceability you can search
through product time events say
engineers and execs can solve problems
quality failures machine failures in
minutes instead of weeks or months and
also of course label and classify the
data in different states so they can
share and collaborate but also build up
machine learning models so we can take
them even a step further on making
things more efficiently making things
better in the same way that we build
tools and capabilities that allows our
customers the men and women on the
factory floors every day
build better products and run their
factories more efficiently Google cloud
builds products and tools allows us to
build better products faster and run our
operations more efficiently we probably
wouldn't feel comfortable scaling up to
thousands and thousands of factories
with tens of thousands of machines all
streaming data if we didn't know we had
the infrastructure of Google to allow us
to do that with that said I want to hand
over to Herman from improbable and say
thank you
[Applause]
[Music]
hello it's absolute pleasure to be here
so if we want to build massive gigantic
simulations of virtual worlds or
completely new ways of modeling cities
or cells or economies huge simulations
at one on thousands of cause it's a real
challenge today it's something that
previously has only really been
available to people with supercomputers
and it generally presents a very
challenging programming models for
developers you've got to manage servers
you've got to cope with the
synchronization of information you got
to do so many things beyond just
building your application so atom
probable we've built a distributed
operating system we called spatial OS
that runs on Google Cloud and makes it
possible to build these kinds of
applications exactly the types of
virtual worlds and massive simulations
that we've all dreamed of but put into
the hands of developers so that it can
be iterated on and built quickly and
efficiently and at the end of last year
we announced a massive innovation
program with Google which makes it
almost completely free for hundreds of
game studios to build completely new
applications on top of spatial OS and
though this first program was targeted
in gaming and it's only been a couple
months there's been an enormous number
of really cool products produced I want
to show you some examples of some of
those these include virtual worlds like
worlds adrift there are 2,000 square
kilometers in size walls with their own
ecologies walls with massive numbers of
players sharing the same space no more
shouting normal separation experiences
that in many cases have been built by
teams of three or five developers and
our beta is live and active right now
and with the community were continually
improving and adding to what spatial OS
can do for gaming but today I'm actually
here to talk to you about the next step
the really big significant and important
problems which one one moment we will
soon be able to talk about
slide transition there we go so thinking
about large-scale simulation as a way of
solving problems a good way to begin is
to think about an example think about
the most important decision that a
company or a government makes right
let's take an example of what that could
look like imagine thinking about how to
change a massive cellular network that
stands an entire city or a country any
change you might think of making whether
it's a modification to the
infrastructure a change to a protocol or
an alteration in policy is going to have
millions of cascading effects which are
incredibly difficult to comprehend or
think about and the reason for this is
that we're dealing really with emergent
systems and this is an idea I want to
put across today the idea that our world
the cells in your body our economy is
the big infrastructure that we build
together they all represent millions of
complex emergent systems and if we
really want to understand these systems
we have to go a lot further than just
using machine learning or past data we
need to learn to completely recreate
these systems in their entirety I mean
actually replicating entire cities on
massive simulations building models of
these networks that have never been
possible for this is a gigantic and
daunting technical challenge it can't be
solved through parallel large-scale
parallel systems we need to build new
kinds of semi parallel distributed
system that can make this stuff work and
if we really want to change our world we
need developers like you to be able to
run these systems in real time build new
businesses and build new services that
run on top of this stuff and that's
precisely what we've been doing with
spatial OS Anam please state to announce
that we're going to be open sourcing
more and more content and showing more
and more frameworks over the course of
the next six months they're gonna make
it possible for more developers to
attack new problem domains and just like
Google with the spirit of open
development and sharing content we
intend to do everything we can to foster
a community where developers can share
code share frameworks share integrations
and start to build and create new
services and businesses we don't all
have to start from scratch we can start
to create an ecosystem to make this
stuff possible and that's why we've
chosen to partner with Google we truly
believe that the cloud is not going to
be a zero-sum game and the age of closed
systems and trying to in
fact hot house developers into
committing to a closed ecosystem are
over we can't succeed unless you succeed
and I think Google recognizes that and
that's the genuine reason why I'm here
today
why we've chosen to make this
partnership happen we're also going to
be announcing incredible new
integrations with services ranging from
machine learning simulations and that
can be added into our tech -
integrations with services like YouTube
which we'll be talking more about this
year that are gonna make our technology
even more functional and even more
useful to you so I've talked a lot about
what's possible I haven't shown you
anything really cool yet so I want to
show you something that we built in
conjunction with the UK government it's
been pretty secret until just basically
this week and I'm finally able to show
it to you this is the largest simulation
of its kind ever created
this is a complete simulation of an
entire UK city its telco network its
power grid its transport network its
sewage systems its housing demographics
even the way in which people move around
and interact with the city we're going
to be open sourcing some of this content
later this year this runs on thousands
of cores and it's able to run in real
time using unity for visualization and
interaction with the simulation this has
already started to transform the way as
we look at cascading failure in emergent
systems change how we do infrastructure
planning change how we think about
running services and my contention to
you today is that this is the future for
how we're going to look at how all the
systems our world operate not just
looking at past data but we creating
them rethinking how we can make these
what-if decisions there's even companies
that are beginning to use special to run
systems of autonomous vehicles being
able to manage them as fleets so I want
to leave you with an idea this thing
here AI Google talks about it all the
time
you can't go on TechCrunch without
saying an AI article but this idea we're
creating reality building reality scale
simulations and services is just as
important and I believe it's going to
underpin how our world is going to
transform whether it's simulations of
tumors in cells that can help us
understand disease or models of
infrastructure that can help us save
money and make better choices so with
your help and the ability to build an
open community on our technology we hope
to kickstart this if you're excited
please check out what we have online you
can download our SD
right now and get started making games
thank you hi let's give a round of
applause to will Willam and Herman who
are doing such great work the Google
Cloud
if you're here on Wednesday
you probably heard one of our many
exciting announcements that we at Google
have acquired Kaggle so I am thrilled to
be able to invite the CEO on stage with
us now to share a few thoughts about
what that means please join me in
welcoming Anthony Goldblum
[Music]
[Applause]
so Anthony when we first met a couple of
years ago we talked about Kaggle as
being this great place for machine
learning competition and then when we
connected more recently I got to learn
about some of the great new innovations
and where the company is going can you
share a little bit about the evolution
of cable yeah sure
so Allyson as you said Carroll started
out running machine learning
competitions and still I would I suspect
that is the thing we're most well-known
for but our vision for Carroll is to
become much bigger we want to be the
place where data scientists do all of
their data science so in August last
year we launched an open data platform
so this is a place we have a very large
community and this is a place where they
can share and collaborate on open
datasets and so people in our community
will publish datasets through this
platform we have everything from very
granular real estate datasets from
around the u.s. through to I think we
have datasets on all contestants for the
first 21 seasons of The Bachelorette or
all their profiles so turns out our
users have very eclectic tastes the
other thing we have launched as a
platform for cattle kernels for
reproducible data science so this allows
data scientists to train train models
using our or Python and share them in an
easily reproducible way so if you wanted
to predict who's gonna win season 22 of
The Bachelorette rather than starting
with a blinking cursor you can go and
see what others in our community have
already done that's so great I love how
kernels are really a great evolution of
Kaggle and I'm excited to see how the
community will now engage with that I
know all of us at Google are very
excited to have you as part of our team
and I'm interested to hear from you
about what it means to haggle to mean
part of Google absolutely I think this
is gonna be huge for our community so if
you think about machine learning
historically machine learning has well
first of all we have a very large
community it's about 850,000 they share
lots of data sets and lots of capital
panels so a lot of code within Google
but if you look at where machine
learning was a few years ago what data
science who was mostly training models
like logistic regression and random
forests which you can easily do on a
single machine
machine learning has really evolved it's
far more sophisticated now and we can do
much much more powerful things but our
community so in joining with Google we
give our community access to the world's
most advanced machine learning cloud and
so we're going to enable far far far
more our community to do far more
powerful things I think it's gonna be
it's gonna be a very exciting journey
with you guys well thank you so much I'm
really looking forward to working
together thank you thank you so we
believe that competition inspires
creativity and in that spirit I have one
final announcement to make here at
Google cloud next we are announcing a
machine learning startup competition so
that we can work with all of you to
think about how we can continue to grow
and build and create great companies so
what does that mean well here is the
entry criteria this competition is open
to early-stage startups as the name
would suggest all implementing machine
learning but not just Google clouds
machine learning but any machine
learning and our spirit of openness and
finally this is open to any vertical
from energy to retail to healthcare we
are excited to work with startups of all
kinds and in all spaces thinking about
how to leverage machine learning to
build great things and as for the prizes
there's two sets of prizes the first
from Google so Google is going to be
offering up to 1 million dollars of GCP
credits actually not up to 1 million 1
million dollars of GCP credits to the
winner in addition we are offering the
opportunity to work one-on-one with our
Google engineers to continue to build in
tune your models and of course G suite
seats but beyond Google's prizes I'm
excited that we have prizes from another
community and that's DC partners we've
teamed up with 7
rate firms Sequoia kleiner perkins GV
data collective emergence capital
Andreessen Horowitz and graylek partners
who are all providing support in
connection with us competition and hot
off the press two of these firms have
now stepped forward data collective an
emergence capital to offer investments
to the winner so each of these firms is
planning to offer five hundred thousand
dollars to the winner of this startup
competition so now I'm pleased to
welcome on stage partners from each of
these firms Santee Sioux Petrovsky from
emergence capital and Matt Akko from
data collective who are going to share a
little bit about what they're looking
for when they think about machine
learning startups please join me in
welcoming Santee and Matt
[Music]
sontee first of all thank you for
teaming up with us it's I'm really
excited about this competition as you
know I have a background in venture and
I love working with early-stage
companies all of us do at Google
and so I wanted to give you each of you
an opportunity to share what you're
excited about and what you're looking
for in these early stage
ml companies now let's start with you
okay so to understand what we're looking
for first you have to understand a
little bit about our firm VCS are fond
of saying we manage 10 billion dollars
or you know we were the first investors
in Genentech or something like that I'll
simplify it we have a double handful of
partners who invest in us our limited
partners they aggregate about a trillion
dollars of liquid capital and they
entrust us with a reasonable percentage
of that to back ambitious ideas from
folks like yourself what we're looking
for
broadly are people attempting the
impossible we're not interested in apps
we're not interested in widgets we
invest in what's colloquially known as
deep tech and to give you a sense of
that I grew up in a dark desperate
polluted time no not today the 1970s
when a 1 megahertz processor was a thing
of wonder and 16 K of RAM was a blessing
I watched my great-uncle spend a year at
Stanford sequencing a single gene when
the space shuttle launched even when it
rolled out of the hangar with the word
Enterprise on it my nerds heart left
with joy these were crude painful things
relative to what we have in hand now and
thanks to Moore's law thanks to a
self-reinforcing virtuous cycle of of
algorithmic innovation we have the
ability to
exponentially go beyond what I grew up
with what was true in the past we're
looking for people who apply deep
compute deep tech novel algorithms
proprietary data to attack the
impossible in gigantic industries and
create multi-decade monopolies that's
how we make our money but that's also as
hackneyed as this phrase maybe make the
world a better place and what we're
looking for is people who will accept
that challenge will rise to that
challenge and make something great thank
you so much so thank you Allison and
we're super thrilled to be partnering
with Google and with data collective on
this competition just to give you a
little bit of background at emergence
we've been investing in enterprise cloud
companies for the last 15 years and as
early believers we saw this massive
tectonic shift from client-server to the
cloud now we believe were starting to
see another massive change with
artificial intelligence and machine
learning and it's gonna happen in the
next 10 years and we believe it's gonna
affect every process within enterprises
and the way we think about this is most
enterprise cloud companies are taking
workflows and moving them to the cloud
with machine learning and artificial
intelligence we feel that we can start
bending those workflows and closing the
loop and creating what we call a
coaching cloud where you can close the
loop and automatically the system gets
better and better every time a new
workflow is being processed we're
excited because we believe that that has
a potential of disrupting the now
incumbents of the cloud if they don't
move fast enough and that's what we like
to do I mean we like to build great
thing with our entrepreneurs and in
terms of the areas where we see this
happening just think about where there's
a ton of data and words there's human
interaction think of I don't know
low-hanging fruit CRM
customer success marketing ton of data
and a lot of repeated processes that
should be getting better and better
automatically as you close this loop and
we're also excited because we did
something similar ten years ago and the
winner of that competition was a company
called service max that recently got
acquired by GE for about a billion
dollars so we expect to replicate that
outcome with Google and data collective
in an even more meaningful way well that
sounds great because we were thinking
about investing between all of us two
million dollars in the winner and a
billion dollar outcome is something that
I'm sure everybody would love to see so
thank you very much thank you
[Applause]
[Music]
and this brings us to the end of our
keynotes
for Google cloud next it has been an
incredible three days on Wednesday we
had the opportunity to hear from Google
leaders and Enterprise companies that
are truly engaging and building with
Google cloud and using G suite to really
collaborate in their organizations
yesterday we saw had got to listen to
over two dozen product announcements and
exciting growth areas in our products
and saw demos of those if you didn't
catch them live be sure to look at them
on YouTube and then today I really
enjoyed hearing about the open cloud
community and how startups are building
with Google cloud I want to give you a
moment and a little information about
some future events coming up so we're
going to be going global with Google
cloud next London and Tokyo and then
please save the date for 2018 back here
in San Francisco and finally I want to
thank all of you who have been here and
engaging with us over the last three
days and a big thank you also to all of
the Googlers that have helped bringing
us all
on behalf of everyone at Google cloud
what really inspires us and motivates us
it's bringing great technology to market
and thinking about what all of us can
build together so thank you very much
for being part of us this great
conference and I'd like to close with a
photo montage of some of my favorite
moments over the last three days thank
you very much
[Applause]
[Music]
you